[Music]
Kelsey's cousin is Gen Z probably the
young gen Z like I think he's 14. this
is the most Boomer conversation I mean
it [ __ ] is but this is kind of funny
he's 13 or something like that anyways
we're up for dinner with his dad
yesterday and they're talking about how
his him and his girlfriend broke up it's
because his girlfriend wanted him to use
more emojis when they texted and he he
refused I was like that's hard as hell
nah I don't [ __ ] with those little
pictures
no it's just lamb yeah I just say what I
feel need another Alpha fee like me who
just says what she feels and then a
[ __ ] little picture to tell you what
you feel
what was his reason he just yeah he was
like if I I mean like it was because you
know she wanted him to be like more
loving and he's like I'm not I'm not
feeling it I'm not gonna send it um how
old is he he's like 13 or something yeah
you know I'm not feeling it I'm not
gonna send it yeah yeah I don't just
send devil emojis just to send them like
you kind of gotta like extract that
emotion from me you know what I'm saying
like Okay like I'm about to play
fortnite with my boys and yeah like for
sure I'm throwing like a devil Emoji
it's like for keeping it a hundred most
deaf I'm putting that [ __ ] in there
but I'm just like talking to my shorty
like if the conversations like drive
it's like mid then what do you want me
to do about that it was kind of love I
kind of love that that uh to take that
what is this yeah yeah that's what you
sounded like yeah yeah it's washed up to
Minnie and I tell her like this look
I got plenty of other mice like you so
like what are we doing here it means
nothing to me this relationship
I'm really out here [ __ ] boy Mickey
that's funny I told you Minnie you
better get a goofy okay
there's a big old dog down the street
you can [ __ ] with him when you're
[ __ ] with me it's all my time you
understand I got mice out here he's like
a Reddit nice guy yeah yeah Gars Minnie
let me suck your toes
I want to lick the bottom of your feet a
mouse like me doesn't got time for this
[ __ ] Minnie on Jesus Christ I got a
theme park to run [ __ ] if you want to
call me toxic I'm that I'm him
I got 10 other mice right here
I'm not sending no Emojis to any of
these [ __ ]
I might [ __ ] around go head down to
Toontown and give me some rabbit head
you feel what I'm saying
I mean a nice snow bunny you should blow
my [ __ ] top to bottom
and then as soon as Minnie gets with
Goofy I can't believe you yeah yeah
you broke my [ __ ]
she's just level-headed as hell yeah
Mickey we talked about this
I try to open up to you and
um
now we're here and I didn't want it to
be like this either but
this is where we're at I swear to God
bro all women are the same
yeah it's a little [ __ ] uh rabbit head
I might not be a rabbit but a [ __ ] like
one you understand
Cody's whole family
um I'm so spam dude I'm just I've been
laughing for two hours straight yeah I
got a dip I'm dead man that was fun I
had a blast I'm just I'm [ __ ]
completely spent
I also woke up at 4 30 a.m so yeah
all right
that's not over it's over
yeah keep going with that don't [ __ ]
kill my vibe is he I feel like he's a
rapper that like hasn't blown up no he's
like yeah you know just wait till
tomorrow
oh you just wait no I think he's more
like uh
Like A Drop Shipping bro okay like some
dude from like South Dakota yeah learned
a lot of Internet culture yeah yeah okay
I see yeah I like that he's he's deeply
hurt inside yeah he's just mad at the
world and he's trying to get rich yeah I
don't have [ __ ] feelings
I don't care I don't care about these
mice I don't care about mice like a
rabbit I get mice
like a human not [ __ ] robot I don't
care
I'll go to Cars Land and [ __ ] one of
them
I put my dick in a Chevron car no
problem
what are the other like Disneylands like
with the other like land yeah yeah no
yeah but he said Toontown I I don't know
anything after autopia Galaxy's Edge and
Avenger campus Avenger campus
that sounds so lame any jokes there
okay yeah there's plenty I'm just you
know I'm just letting you just guiding
you I'm just like throwing throwing
throwing up passes for you to dunk
Thanos that's my guy